and as a part of Europe emigration is
inevitable if you were elected how would
you address the issue of immigration
Joan thank you very much indeed for that
ed movement Joan thank you for your
question I've changed Labor's approach
on immigration because I don't think
it's prejudice to worry about
immigration I think people's concerns
are real and they've got to be dealt
with and I want to explain how we'll
deal with them if I'm elected as prime
minister we'll put in place new rules
which say that if you come to this
country you won't get benefits for at
least the first two years I will also do
something else which I think is of a
concern to many people in that country
will stop the undercutting of wages and
conditions that happen so often
employers exploiting migrant labor not
paying the minimum wage recruiting only
from abroad to undercut wages they've
been just to prosecution's for failure
to pay the minimum wage in the last five
years got to deal with it and if I'm
Prime Minister I will there's one other
thing I'll say to you that if you want a
party that will cut Britain off from the
rest of the world that's not me I
believe we've got to play our role in
the world but if you want a party with
controls on immigration that's what I
offer everyone thank you very much
indeed
Leon would play Camry won't go along
with the scapegoating of migrants it was
not polish care workers or Estonian bar
workers who caused this economic crisis
it was bankers and we shouldn't allow
the rhetoric that blames immigrants for
all of our ills there's a reason why
there's a strong anti-immigration
feeling in areas where there is little
immigration and that's because often
those areas have not shared in the
wealth that has been generated there are
gaps in the Welsh economy and there are
certain skills that we need but sadly
the debate around immigration has
stopped those gaps being filled we
talked earlier on about the Welsh NHS we
have fewer doctors per head of the
population in ways than other parts of
the EU
and this immigration debate has not
helped that problem it's exacerbated it
yeah I'm good thank you
Nicola Sturgeon Jordan we do need strong
and effective controls on immigration we
need to make sure people don't get away
with abusing the systems that the rest
of us pay for we also need to recognize
it in parts of the UK that are a strain
on hosting and public services I take
the view though that the answer to that
is investing more in homes and in our
public services and in enforcing a
decent minimum wage not in scapegoating
immigrants and I think the views of the
Westminster parties on this issue have
been driven by the fear of UK rather
than by rational debate and I think we
need to have a balanced debate so here's
some facts that we need to bear in mind
EU immigrants are net contributors to UK
public finances the majority of migrants
work a majority of those who don't work
are students and let's also not forget
that hundreds of thousands of British
citizens go to live in other countries
how would we feel if they were spoken
about or treated in the way that
migrants often hire so let's have a
debate let's not duck the issues but
let's make sure it's a decent and a
civilized debate not one that's driven
by the intolerance of Nigel Farage
Nicola Sturgeon thank you David Cameron
well thank you Jane for your question
what we need in our country is to
recognize that people who come here and
work hard and contribute to our
companies and to our communities they
help make this a great country but we do
need immigration that's controlled and
fair and in recent decades it has been
too high and I want to see it come down
now we have reduced immigration from
outside the EU not least by putting in
place a cap on people coming to work
here but inside the EU not least because
we've created more jobs than the rest of
the European Union put together
immigration has been very high so we
need to bring that under control and
here are the proposals that I will put
in place as Prime Minister first if
you're coming from the European Union
you won't get unemployment benefit
second if you've been here for six
months and don't have a job you'll have
to go home third if you've come here and
worked you'll have to work for four
years paying into the system before you
get out of the system and finally if you
leave your family at home you won't be
able to send child benefit as you
and now back to your family at home
those are fair changes that I can
deliver David Cameron Thank You Nigel
fire well Jen I told you at the start
they were all the same but they all
agreed and they do they all agree they
should be part of the European Union so
the answer to your question is as
members of the EU what can we do to
control immigration let me tell you
nothing nothing the Prime Minister can
talk about benefits ed Miliband talk
about benefits this isn't about benefits
this is about numbers we have a total
open door to 10 former communist
countries and to the eurozone where
people are suffering very very badly
I don't blame a single migrant that
comes to Britain from Eastern Europe
wanting to better their lot
it is depressed wages it has led to such
a crisis in housing you know we have to
build a new house one house every 7
minutes just to cope with current levels
of immigration we need to change our
relationship with Europe too what a
trade and friendship take back control
of our borders and put in place an
Australian style point system and 77% of
British people want something done Nigel
Farage thank you Nick Clegg well I will
never spread fear about immigration
because I think we just need to remember
there's basically good immigration as
bad immigration and Joan in a bad
immigration of course that needs to be
stopped that's why I've introduced new
checks at the borders to bear down on
illegal immigration why I've increased
the penalties against unscrupulous
employers who employ people and exploit
them from elsewhere why if people now
want to seek benefits they have to learn
English but there is also good
immigration we should remain a decent
generous hearted open-minded nation who
welcomes people who want to come here
play by the rules pay their taxes create
jobs help in the NHS if we turn
everybody away the NHS would collapse
overnight
so I guess my approach to immigration
could be summarised simply as this that
I want Britain to be open for business
but not open to abuse Nick Clegg thank
you nothing Bennet well first of all in
terms of European immigration we
celebrate the free movement of people in
the EU and as Nicola alluded to many
Britons have been able to take advantage
of that to do what they want with their
life that's a real plus
but if we think about non-eu immigration
what we need is a controlled but fair
and humane system and that's not what
we've got now just take one example the
facts that a quarter of appeals against
asylum refusal people have often been
victims of torture in their own country
these people we've come here with less
than four years and then eventually say
yes you are a refugee after all now I
think when people talk to me about
immigration they often say they're
concerned about three things they're
concerned about low wages crowded
schools and hospitals and housing
problems all of those are important
critical issues we need to deal with but
they're not caused by immigration
they're caused by failures of government
policy